As residents of the District of Rochford,
we all have a responsibility to do whatever
is within our power to prevent all
forms of victimization and genocide.
The Statement of Commitment will be read by
Councillor Mike Wilkinson. We recognise The
Holocaust shook the foundations of modern
civilization. It's unprecedented character
and horror will always hold universal meaning. We
believe The Holocaust must have a permanent place
in our nation's collective memory. We honor the
survivors still with us and reaffirm our shared
goals of mutual understanding and justice. We must
make sure that future generations understand the
causes of The Holocaust and reflect upon its
consequences we vow to remember the victims of
nazi persecution and of all genocide. We value the
sacrifices of those who have risked their lives
to protect or rescue victims, as a touchstone of
the human capacity for good in the face of evil.
We recognize that humanity is still scarred
by the belief that race, religion, disability
or sexuality makes people's lives
worth less than others. Genocide,
anti-semitism, racism, xenophobia
and discrimination still continue.
We have shared responsibility to fight these
evils. We pledge to strengthen our efforts
to promote education and research about The
Holocaust and other genocide. We will do our
utmost to make sure that the lessons of such
events are fully learned. We will continue to
encourage Holocaust Remembrance by commemorating
UK Holocaust Memorial Day. We condemn the evils.